welcome to this video I'm playing some
buca from the UK and playing a silly and
yellow there should be five is my my
preferred move then can also castle yeah
okay come let's do that one is also not
bad at all this intends to to keep the
bishop this line has been played yeah
quite a number of times recently one
game was the game Carlton against Boris
Gelfand in the candidates tournament in
London probably carved in some best game
in this tournament it was a bit
different I think galphin played nine f6
instead of taking okay try to play
against the week weekend pawns seaforth
actually a move that you could have a
debatable booth maybe it was was better
to not play it because I'm young I'm
weakening and weakening some squares
here and the bishop on earth one is also
not happy but yeah maybe I shouldn't
have done that hmm okay yeah I could
have played Knight d2 and to delay the
smooth until in the
until the moment is more appropriate
yeah if I am NOT worse but it's not
really too exciting
damn and it's a problem I mean I have if
I would have taken on the aid um 50
maybe Bishop 86 coming but taking on dat
immediately asked this night situ idea
which is some really annoying okay so
should I take now
or or activate the Queen yeah more
probably most my chances are still best
in an end game so let's trade
so be 3m covering the pawn and making
sure that mmm it's not playing a form i
wanted to say i have forgot about bishop
f6 which is so really bad hmm
ah i should add this is not exactly
rocket science this move and I just just
forgot it forgot that it is possible
check okay okay mom I can even play 93 I
thought 93 I just play rock t 1 but the
brook rd adis of course just protected
mm yeah then this is just good 93 you
can take on c3 of course but I'm not
this is not so convincing in comparison
giving up the bishop am but 93 is much
stronger just giving like a big
advantage I need to take okay okay okay
maybe it's not so clear actually I can
play Knight a form threatening 95 okay
this is lucky yeah well okay this was
always a possibility but I thought that
it was not so convincing due to various
reasons the ship c7 is one of them I
wonder I kept I could even play it now i
can take here Bishop Jason Dave form
yeah moving moving in the rook is more
logical anyway well
looxcie to eat here Scotty got a tempo
hmm
yeah look do you want is not not really
a problem okay it's always a prayer
tricky if the poet can can enter on the
first rank but it doesn't seem seem
problematic here
Oh interesting he wants to he wants to
play rook to e1 now but I have rookie
three ah then he can take on everyone
very nicely played on everyone look at
one king of one Bishop c4 King it to a
night before blah that's that's really
bad
Wow does this mean i don't have a
defense this would be really bad at
yeah i don't i don't see a defense that
any any tricks at least
Jim yeah this is the only thing I can
think of check yeah yeah I saw that I
mean my ideas to go here and then play
Bishop g6 try to play against the night
yeah it's lost I know but not ready to
resign yet
yeah well it's it's okay
hmm yeah he's he's controlling all the
squares I'm indeed he played he played
in a way that high morning his own
Bishop is is bad now but I quit his own
night I mean but he controls all the
square so there's no player on white
person yeah I 41 was very strong I mean
I completely overlooked this Bishop f6
move which is very very easy just I just
forgot about it b3 it shouldn't be
terrible but the way I played it was
immediately lost the thing is I white is
what is just better yeah I guess the
shop c7 b3 is just this kind of lazy
convenience moves that you may go let's
protect it and so on but this is just
much better this is just excellent for
white dumb you have the trade i have the
default mean why does much better here
after be 3 i'm in trouble check I mean
it probably should have some way to to
defend but the problem is this move if I
was just very strong I need to do
something else
yeah probably i need to play that it's
um the fun thing is if you look at it
and yeah why does just fine you
threatening Bishop c7 picking up the
pond and if he would allow that I mean
I'm just much better so he needs to do
something like ninety three or a four
they will 93 I have this one so a form
takes know that one
gal black should be able to draw but
white is just the 12 to dictate the game
yeah rookie 3 is just a big blunder but
a 4 is a nice refutation really when I
took relatively quickly simply
everything else looked strange but the
added there's probably by a better
defense technically but i mean it's also
threatening to play a three yeah this is
just completely lost and nice or really
nice i fail to recognize the the a41
idea this is still perfectly okay looked
a bit strange to lose those tempe but
it's just better i mean okay one is also
a move okay interesting thanks for
watching